three engines up and burning - one zero
and liftoff the final liftoff of
Atlantis shoulders of the Space Shuttle
America will continue the dream that was
the last time NASA astronauts flew to
the International Space Station on an
American spacecraft
it was nearly eight years ago since then
NASA has relied on Russia for rides but
that could soon change early tomorrow
SpaceX will launch its new spaceship on
a critical test flight this will be the
first time a commercially built and
operated spaceship capable one day of
carrying people will travel to the space
station
mark Strassmann is at the launch pad on
Merritt Island at Kennedy Space Center
in Florida mark good morning good
morning now this is very unusual access
we're right at launch pad 39a from here
Apollo 11 blasted off to the moon and
most space shuttle missions are headed
to the International Space Station
behind me you can see SpaceX's Falcon 9
rocket and at the very top is what this
launch demonstration is all about its
crew Dragon capsule while no one will be
riding inside it SpaceX has everything
riding on the success of this mission
its final approach for NASA astronauts
Bob Behnken and Doug Hurley straight
ahead the International Space Station
but they're not 250 miles above Earth
this is a training simulation at the
headquarters of SpaceX in Hawthorne
California capture confirmed attenuation
bankin and Hurley both Space Shuttle
veterans will be the first astronauts to
climb aboard a falcon 9 rocket and into
space X's new ship called crew dragon
and liftoff falcon 9 is the company
workhorse launching 20 times last year
but crew dragon needs a successful test
flight called
demo one before SpaceX can fly people
the goal prove it can safely dock and
undock from the space station
reenter the Earth's atmosphere and
splashdown off the Florida coast and we
have shut this down the
our mission is riding on the success of
demo1 certainly the only way to really
demonstrate it is to fly it improve it
you know I'm from st. Louis Missouri
it's the the show-me state and having
those successes under your belt goes a
long way to given confidence and if
something's gonna go wrong you want it
to go wrong when it's uncrewed yeah when
we're not on the rocket absolutely the
final liftoff of Atlantis shoulders of
the Space Shuttle America will continue
the dream once the space shuttle program
ended in 2011 nASA has had one option to
get to the space station hitch a ride
with the Russians a round-trip ticket on
a Soyuz rocket cost 81 million dollars
per seat that is now changing NASA has
hired tube companies SpaceX and Boeing
to design and build new space taxis we
are on the brink of launching American
astronauts on American Rockets from
American soil
Jim bridenstine is NASA's administrator
some of this is American pride prestige
I like to use the word prestige great
nations should be able to launch their
own astronauts into space both companies
have learned space is hard both are
running more than two years behind
schedule and with neither yet certified
to fly people NASA is considering buying
two more Soyuz seats to guarantee
continued American access to the space
station are you concerned about the
delays so we don't like delays we don't
like delays but worse than a delay is
launching something that's not ready
mission success and safety is the number
one overriding concern and we're not
going to do anything to put these crew
in jeopardy
there is no cost or schedule pressure
here whatsoever now inside the crew
Dragon capsule SpaceX is sending a dummy
named Ripley a smart dummy equipped with
sensors all over to gauge the impact of
this flight biana Boeing is also having
a flight demonstration just like this
one it'll be next month it will send up
its spaceship called Starliner there's
literally a new frontier market and we
are
and crew dragon a very successful
mission thank you so much